I find good CEOs to run the key to
individual companies and so we have you
know we have these three hundred CEOs
out there around the world who are
leading leading them to leading the
fight I take a a chairman role so you
know my either way I split my time is
about 50% on you know social projects
and that and that's increased over the
years of the other 50% about a third is
spent firefighting when we have a
problem about a third is spent on
developing the companies that you know
we've already got going and the other
third is may be spent on getting new
companies going and then in between all
that you know I have to get out there
and try to make sure that version
becomes the most respected brand in the
world and one way of making sure it
world is to get out there and talk about
what we're doing and help you know
promote and get get the brand in
people's minds and support all the
people out there working hard to build
it I mean the you know the company is
made up of 300 individual companies it's
very unusual for a Western company in
fact perhaps it's unusual for you know
for even an Eastern company in a sense
where a way of life company I mean
you've got you know the better known
brands in the West coca-cola specialize
in soft drinks Microsoft and computers
Nike and shoes and so it goes on you
know version can look after your needs
from the time you were born almost at
the time your time you'd I haven't quite
got diversion funerals yet but and they
and but and the reason for that is you
know I I love life I love learning about
new things I love you know you know if I
see that something could be done better
I'd love to you know challenge myself
and the people around to see it week
do it better and I'm inquisitive you
know I've just come from the beach
English wonderful man called Vinod
Khosla where we've been talking about
you know you know what we've been
discovering unclean fuels what he's been
discovering on clean fuels and you know
sharing ideas credibly exciting to see
if we can come up with a fuel that can
replace the conventional dirty fuels
that's destroying our planet and so and
you know so just learning and living
life to its full now that you know
process of being an entrepreneur who's
learnt a lot can be very useful in then
tackling some of the global problems
that we face you know I just mentioned
fuels massive problem that the world
faces this global warming is going to
affect all countries in the world and in
particular the poorer countries and
ultimately could literally you know mean
the end of end of mankind itself but you
know man
has the brains and the intelligence to
do something about it and and you know
we're going to play a major part in
trying to do something about it and
that's the kind of entrepreneurial
charitable in a sense you know approach
that we're now taking through new
ventures